the rice milk and the coconut milk and
the almond milk are very low in protein
so if you're looking to get a protein
source like a vegetarian or plant-based
protein source these are not very good
that's registered dietitian Mary
encroach today she's gonna help us sort
through all of these different non-dairy
milks and tell us which ones might just
be better for you in the last several
years the market for non-dairy milks has
exploded and that's great for the some
sixty-five percent of adults who are
lactose intolerant but with more than a
dozen varieties now crowding the dairy
aisle it's hard to know which one to
choose ultimately grouch says it comes
down to what you're looking for
so if you're looking to get closest to
cow's milk I would probably go with the
soy milk just because it has more
protein it has about 7 grams of protein
per cup as opposed to 8 grams in cow's
milk and then oat milk is somewhere in
between without 4 grams of protein per
cup of oat milk soy is high in protein
because it comes from a bean whereas oh
it comes from a grain and it tends to
have less protein in it the protein in
the soy milk is also more complete if
you're looking to reduce your calories
almond milk might be a good choice so
the rice milk here is higher in calories
or the highest in calories and then we
have oat soy coconut and almond milk is
usually the lowest in calories but if
you're trying to watch your fat intake
you may actually want to avoid coconut
milk so soy has about 4 grams of fat per
cup and again these are healthier fats
than the fat that you might find in a 2%
milk but its equivalent in the amount of
oat milk about about 3 grams it depends
on the brand coconut milk is a little
bit higher it's about 6 grams of fat I
don't really see the benefit to coconut
milk it's higher in saturated fats
although now we know that the saturated
fat in coconut is probably not as
detrimental to cardiovascular health as
we once thought but I think the jury is
still out and I wouldn't be taking a lot
of saturated fats from coconut products
right now
but when you're choosing which milk to
buy there's more to consider than just
protein calories and fat most of them
are fortified with vitamin D vitamin A
vitamin b12 but you have to purchase a
fortified milk so some are fortifying up
to 45% of the daily value for calcium
whereas others are only fortifying up to
10% so this rice milk is fortified with
30% of the daily value so the daily
value for calcium is 1,000 milligrams
and that covers most people so 30% per
cup would mean 300 milligrams of calcium
per cup and that's equivalent to cow's
milk coconut milk actually is only
fortified at 10% so you'd only get 100
milligrams of calcium per cup so it'd be
difficult to meet your calcium needs if
you're relying on a product like this
for for calcium they're mostly not
fortified with other nutrients like
potassium soy milk actually is a good
source of potassium but some of the
others are not so it really just depends
on on the milk and how it's fortified it
depends on on the brand and that's just
it nutrients don't just vary by type of
milk like almond or soy but by brand
like blue diamond or silk and so do
calories in fat so the best way to
choose the right milk is simple check
out the label
you